how do you figure out who to trust in
your life you're joe rogan a lot of
people want to be close to you cia
agents fsb agents
uh
people that want i'm friends with a
former cia agent mike baker who's been
on my podcast a bunch of times allegedly
former former think about that he's air
quotes former yeah yeah i don't believe
he's former he's problem sure he has
some connection to him i also believe
he's a good guy
but i gain a lot of very intelligent and
well-informed insights from him as to
how things work and you know
i think uh
yeah i'm sure he doesn't tell me
everything about everything but he's
told me enough where i i think i can
understand things better from talking to
him about how the way
you know
the elves
work under the machine what what about
friends how do you know if you can trust
well most of my friends are old friends
time so time is the thing yeah like uh
just going through [ __ ] together yeah
and so much people that
you know
first of all comics like
you can trust comics yeah comments are
pretty trustworthy the good ones the
really good ones there's not that many
of us
if there's a thousand professional
comics on earth i'd be stunned
i'd be stunned i don't even think
there's a thousand like real
professionals who you get booked all the
time headline weekends at clubs and
theaters and arenas
and then there's levels to that right
there's like the guys who are middle
acts who kind of like barely scrape by
and then like how many headliners are
there how many like really funny
headliners that i would say you know if
you lex you tell me you're going to be
in cincinnati hey this person's playing
at this club should i go see them i'd be
like
you know like how many people would i
give the recommendation to
and then how many people sell out
theaters
how many people sell out arenas how many
there's not that [ __ ] many so those
people like at the uh the levels of
comedy where you you know you've been
doing stand-up for 20 years
you there's a certain amount of honesty
and a certain amount of understanding of
each other that we all have oh so that
that process of becoming a great comic
is like humbling in the way like yeah
jiu jitsu is humbling very similar like
there's you've take you've eaten so much
[ __ ] that yeah
that that somehow even if you're insane
if you even if you're chaotic even in
the way
even if you're full of [ __ ] you lie a
lot all those kinds of things underneath
it there's a good human yeah you could
be surface bullshitter but on important
things you're trustworthy
hopefully i mean if you're not then
people shy away from you and there are
people like that too that are really
successful but that are that are what i
call islands
um i've talked to other comics about
that like you don't want to be an island
because there's these people that aren't
attached to the rest of the community
and they're doing well on their own
and usually they have like one opening
act they bring with them on the road
they've worked with forever and they
don't have comedy friends and they're
those people are miserable because they
can't relate sometimes fame in itself is
isolating so you have to actually do a
lot of work and make sure you don't it
doesn't isolate you yes if you become
successful
people start wanting stuff from you yes
and then sometimes you want to push them
away because of that as opposed to uh
connect with them yeah i don't enjoy it
when people want things from me
it's not fun you just ignore it yeah
it's [ __ ] too heavy they want too
much it's it's too much of a
disproportionate relationship
you know it's too unbalanced
because uh there are people where you
could tell that they're working towards
something they're working towards an
angle and they want to be close to you
because you'll you will benefit them and
then there's other people that are just
there's not that many of us and so we
all want to hang out together like when
i one of the podcasts i love the most is
this podcast i do called protect our
parks it's a thing i do with uh ari
shafir shane gillis and mark that's
great it's so fun because we just get
obliterated and we talk so much [ __ ]
like there's conversations after that
podcast where i go hey man we gotta cut
that part out yeah because like shane
will go too far and go too crazy but
we're just making each other laugh and
it's just fun and it's like that kind of
camaraderie between real comics is very
precious to me my favorite part of that
is like the non-sequitur stuff from mark
norman
and you guys get so trashed that you
don't even understand what the hell he's
talking about but it's funny to the
listener
because he's still on point that is as
sharp he's so good mitch hedberg quality
yes
well he's such a such a dedicated comic
you know he loves comedy so much that's
one of the things i love about him he's
like comedy he gets excited like he
loves it as to shane and as does ari
yeah you know they really love it and
it's um that's so so there's that like i
have friends in that way and i have
martial arts friends who are some of the
uh also the thing about being humbled
how things like jiu jitsu will humble
you martial arts friends are they're
also
i they know
they know who's been through it you know
they know who's who really has gone
through the gauntlet and emerged on the
other end
a better person
you